but here comes the airship Wesley this
is the special bit so what you've got is
an extremely powerful piece of weaponry
right here and is it the the British
Army I've got this one right now yeah so
because of that the way it works
essentially is that you want to look at
it is when the team is down
it's that last-ditch opportunity that
last effort to be able to get back into
the game in the airship if used properly
can cause a lot of damage it is a an
incredible incredible piece of weaponry
a behemoth yeah well I mean obviously
though it's a huge target as we can see
it's getting shot already so it's it's
not something that you're likely to miss
in the sky but all that power right
there if you were down and you needed to
take a couple of flags back in conquest
this could give you the power to do that
you can absolutely obliterate people
with the guns that are on it
infantry don't stand a chance so it
really is the last ditch but you could
turn things around the point just landed
right in front of us and it got good
shot there and look at aircrews throwing
down on the PC sup man
you know just looking for that
opportunity thing you found someone in
front of them and just oh now you're
just yelling yeah well I mean again it's
the emotion brought emotion on board
with Snoop Dogg he's in one of the tanks
I think was it the armored car thinking
like that yeah I think that is the tank
very over here Stone Mountain olio be
dealing with a lot of pressure and
seananners coming out of nowhere giving
them the business that's unfortunate one
thing we did see there was one of the
the new movement mechanics the way they
pull yourself gas on top you might have
just seen it before the guy before the
guy hit the floor you can now pull
yourself up for answer cover that's a
lot higher than you so you can use the
cover to your advantage or you can drop
down behind it but then you can spring
out in surprise as well so there are
different kinds of
mechanics in the game that are new as
you had mentioned before the high bolt
as it's called yeah you know other
battlefield games there may have been
like a gate or like you know stone
fencing or something like that the in
couldn't quite get over now you can it's
just all one fluid motion look at the
tank just running through every one here
I don't even know who's in that tank but
he is looking to cause some damage and
here's a couple of interesting notes
about the tank too so you can actually
target damaged tanks this time around
right so if I want to eliminate the
treads I can eliminate the treads I
could do the best I can
- oh okay I was interesting but yeah
like myself the damage is individual to
certain parts but it's not just these
tanks that we've got here there are
different types of tanks in battlefield
1 so you've got light tanks medium tanks
and heavy tanks obviously the name will
tell you a little bit about what they do
but a light tank can only hold one
player so you could be very effective on
your own but if you want to sit down
with some of your squad mates you can
move into a medium tank that's got three
seats in it and if you really want to
take your full squad in in a tank and
you want to go bowling around the
battlefield and just causing absolute
havoc then you can use one of the heavy
tanks that's got five seats in it yeah
and another thing to note is well about
you know just the tanks in general they
are tied to those specific classes right
they contain a variety of weapons
depending on the situation but most
importantly though they contain a repair
hammer right which you can use to
actually give yourself that you know to
keep you alive and keep the keep the
tank going also another thing to know -
and I do want to talk about this you can
actually self repair your tank yes you
can you so you can stay in the tank but
there's a trade-off right like all
things there's a trade-off you actually
cannot get out of the tank you can't
move you can't fire you can't do
anything you're kind of a sitting duck
so while you can't
can't do a lot of things and by the way
each of these powers shootin out oh this
is it this is what we waiting for just
rain and screen and destruction on his
opponent here find someone in front of
them just gonna land on this building
here we go oh boy is good stuff takes it
down takes it down now that's one thing
about the airship if you do spawn in you
happen to be in one of the in the
weapons you want to get back into the
action maybe you want to get a little
bit closer to the enemy you think you
can do some damage or you could just
jump out parachute down and get straight
back into the battle and another thing
you see that bayonet there right the
bayonet if you're sprinting and then you
hit a specific button you can actually
go a little bit faster not only is it a
good escape mechanic potentially if
you're in a bit of a sticky situation
but if you just charge right into
someone you're going to take them on
here we go folks the airship has been
destroyed and it is going to drop
another incredible factoid about this
airship guys it doesn't matter where it
like there's no like pre-programmed like
this is where this is gonna fall no it
balls anywhere all those buildings down
there are watch destroyed just watch
this oh my goodness this is crazy
now I'm insane not just that but once
it's hit the ground its carcass stays
there as well so you have to battle it
out moving through all of this like
metal that's just crashed into the
ground it's it's a ruin at that point
obviously we saw it a little bit of
first-person a little bit of
third-person that the first time I saw
that when I got to play this game
everybody just stood still and watched
it it was absolutely incredible to watch
awesome stuff and there you can see the
remnants of what was there past means
airship it looks fantastic on there cuz
it also just creates a whole new you
know gameplay elements yeah right
because now you got a bob and weave
through this metal yeah I mean like you
could have like taken cover behind some
of those buildings that's not gonna
that's not going to be the case anymore
plus let's say that it does land on all
those buildings you've got that
close-quarters environment well now you
get to see players that are a little bit
further away so it changes up the game a
little bit
let's go here we go Rex factor gaming
nice view with the town here actually
this is this is a nice shot so you can
see all of these buildings here I
believe can be destroyed
there's CaptainSparklez in the tank
there again little reckless finds one in
front of them there that's going to be a
good pickup looking for a second killin
balls gotta get the second pick good job
indeed from x-factor gaming heat every
time we've gone under respect with him
he has been a beast just doing doing the
dirty work man
I expect nothing less from from x-factor
if you've ever played with him or you've
ever had the opportunity to see him play
he is just an extremely good battle plan
Oh
but just as we say that oh no it's the
Joker so the comments say everything is
your concern fall there you have it
folks
congratulations